[Music]
the forest is brimming with wolves it's
my job to hold them down not yours but
we can put them together wolves bears
dragons even
cartoon saloon they make these
profoundly human
films very beautiful very poetic films
something's happened to me i'm a hoof
walker yeah it's flipping great you have
four legs now you can run really fast
and jump so high and in this film the
natural world and the human world are
interconnected always as people become
animals and animals become people
[Music]
cromwellian ireland is a fascinating
period in irish history promo is like
the baddest villain in irish history if
you ask most irish people i want all the
wolves gone from this forest yes my lord
good fellow you have two days funnily
enough he's the hero to a lot of english
people
that's when we had the idea of two kids
one from england one from ireland i'm a
wolf walker when i sleeps i'm a wolf
when i'm awake i meet me
[Music]
what's your name anyway
robin
our two main characters robin and may
had to seem very different
robin would be a lot more subtle in her
movements a little bit more dainty and
maeve is a little bit more broad
[Music]
the thing that made the animation unique
for this production i felt was that
there was a lot of focus on making
things seem very natural
and keeping the lines more loose
[Music]
so for us in the rough animation we
could be a little bit more free you
can't stay in the forest they're cutting
it all down no way i scared them off
[Applause]
the style that we were aiming for was
extremely high
we developed a way of offsetting the
colors outside of the lines to make it
look like mistakes in woodblock printing
the forest line is quite difficult to
color
we developed a style to kind of make the
outside of the color shapes a bit fuzzy
to look like watercolor
we had to do quite a lot of by hand
which took longer but in the end it
looks beautiful
in this film there is this very
interesting relationship with nature in
which nature flows into the human world
and back out again why someone to be
human being a wolf is way better i'll
show you
the amazing thing of working with
cartoon saloon other than the beautiful
animation and the stories smelly little
tony is the fact that something touches
us